if you wrote down your three top
priorities for the day do those first
before you do your social media before
you reply to everyone's DMs I have so
many people they spend all day just
checking their email to reply to
everybody else now that's fine if that's
your job if that's customer service do
that that's your job but if you're an
entrepreneur as an example and you're
just checking into other people's
agendas all day to meet all their
obligations and you keep missing your
key priorities even though you might be
smart you're competent but your brain
doesn't believe you're capable you've
got to develop the pattern of taking the
action so all I want you to do as a
daily simple habit every morning we do
it in the high performance planner I
write down my key priorities for the day
do those first make that happen maybe
that's your morning for me I didn't feel
capable my career for a long time
because I'm replying to everybody and I
did a simple thing I said you know what
no phone calls till 1 pm in the
afternoon my time that leaves the
morning to do the most important work
because I do the most important work
almost every morning of my life I feel
incredibly capable that consistency that
congruence develop the capability now I
feel capable and I am capable because I
executed because I executed so many
times I developed a scale you all follow
this is so important need motivation
watch the top 10 of believe Nation
because I love it hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
you are probably the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best Brendan burchard and my take on
his top 10 was a success
Joy
rule number two accept who you are if
you don't have self-acceptance clearly
you don't have authentic self-confidence
if you don't have self acceptance
clearly you won't have an authentic
sense of happiness because you don't
even like yourself
so what do we do about this when I'm
coaching others well first after I've
tried to understand where that's coming
from that solution driven part of
coaching is about realizing there's
things we all do to gain greater
self-acceptance yourself
wants to realize itself
right we all want to reach a fuller
higher standard of our potential right
we we all want that we I've never met a
person in my life who didn't want to
realize a higher level of potential for
themselves or their family or their
teams or their work and I know some
people like no no you don't know my kid
he's 42 and he's still on the couch I
don't have a judgment for that what I
have to say about that is this
that person does too
it's built in the human spirit
we all want to grow
we all want to be happy
sometimes we get discouraged from that
enough
that we lie to ourselves and say we
don't want it or worse
we don't deserve it
many people don't have self-acceptance
because they don't believe they deserve
it
they think that they did something wrong
they had other people judge them
they had that experience when they've
had so much negativity around them they
started to believe that story
and so what I share with you about
self-acceptance
um it's one of the reasons I'm a very
big proponent of coaching or of therapy
a lot of self-acceptance is actually
socially gained
you know there's a reason that the
psychology department tends to be in the
same building as a sociology Department
because they go hand in hand we are
social animals a lot of your acceptance
of yourself actually has nothing to do
with self-acceptance your acceptance
yourself came from how people treated
you before it was socially gained and
constrained
you started to believe that you were at
a certain level based on how other
people around you treated you isn't true
and one way
to gain greater self-acceptance is to
take back that self part and say oh I'm
gonna do the work on me right now
I'm going to take some time to work on
myself again and I am going to lessen
the noise of the negative people around
me and get around positive people who
amplify the noise of positivity
it doesn't mean get around yes persons
it means get around yes spirited persons
people who are supportive and
encouraging of you you probably have one
positive friend talk to them more often
hang out with them more often lean on
them more
I think that's critical
because the easiest way to develop off
in the self is in our social environment
getting other more positive healthy
people around us tends to lift all boats
the other thing to think about with the
acceptance part
is to learn
to be in the moment in such a way that
you can forgive the things you did in
the past rule number three don't take
things personally calmness comes from
not taking things so personally
not taking things so personally
how critical is this guys
we have become a Twitter Nation you know
we become a culture that completely
takes things super personal escalates
them into you know very aggressive
language
um high levels of accusation and
assumptions we just immediately go from
you know a simple incident
igniting a fury of cancellation and
aggravation
and I really believe it's because you if
you are consuming a lot of social media
are being conditioned
how many times per day every time you do
this
every time you do this on social media
every single scroll every single swipe
is a judgment
your brain is being taught
okay is this relevant or not judgment do
I like it or not like literally do I
like do I press like it or not judgment
is it worth actually giving this a heart
judgment
every single swipe every single scroll
is an automatic training of the brain to
be judgmental
why do we have a culture that takes
things more personally and is more
judgmental against other people because
our culture has been trained by the tens
of millions of times that we have swiped
and scrolled through things to either
hit that like or love button or not and
it has created a speed of judgment in
our lives against others
and about how we perceive ourselves
and so we have a culture that now takes
things everything is so personal because
everything is judged at a heightened
degree binary good or bad like or
dislike and it's poisonous
it's killing us
and so I think it's really important
what do you
tend to get triggered by
what causes you stress or anxiety and if
you could look at it a lot of it is what
you feel are personal attacks where
suddenly you feel very defensive and
that defensiveness leads to stress and
anxiousness because you feel like you
have to defend yourself against other
people maybe your husband says some
accusation or maybe someone says
something on social media and you're
like was that a was that a dig at me
and all of a sudden it's like was that
against me
and a lot of people all day long they're
carrying that they're defensive all day
long and that's why they're stressed
right imagine if a warrior is standing
at the gates of the palace
and every person that walks by they see
as an immediate stressor as an immediate
threat they're keyed up all day they're
stressed they're anxious all day right
acid is just churning in their stomach
these thoughts of what if these horrible
things happen in their brain
that's what it feels like for many
people as they go throughout the day
because they're so worried that their
personal feelings are going to get hurt
or that their personal reputations would
be destroyed or that they're having to
be in a place of Defense
and by the way I don't play light about
that some people really are they have a
very toxic person in their life though I
don't like to use the word toxic I like
to usually talk about oh this person
this person has a set of behaviors that
make you feel a certain way
and those set of behaviors sometimes we
don't want to be around them anymore
we have to minimize ourselves in being
around them
but almost everybody I know takes things
too personally
they get so worked up everything is an
affront against them oh you criticize my
work well your work sucks you know oh
are you saying I didn't get that exactly
right well you'd understand I have 5000
other things and defensive people tend
to be weak people
and I don't mean that weak mentally I
don't mean that weak in terms of an
awful judgment I mean they feel that way
they actually the higher level of
Defense you feel the more threatened you
feel
the more you start to feel like you're
losing control and strength because it's
sapping you
the more you feel personally offended by
things
the more saptive energy you become
and I think this is so important
if you take personal offense to
everything if you're so precious with
feedback where every piece of feedback
you get all worked up about and upset
about
and or everything your friend says about
your house or your clothes or your hair
or your makeup or your weight or your
kids instead of judging so fast about
what someone said about you and how
you're going to feel about it
I would love for you to
lengthen the timeline of judgment rule
number four expand your Social Circle
your environment shapes you because
you're soaking it
and so make sure the relationships you
have are high quality now this is
everyone's but Brandon you understand my
spouse well he's a doozy you know it's
like listen if you're around people
who aren't like this the job isn't to
get rid of them and throw them away
the job is to go build that group
somewhere else
to find that
to find that to build it if you didn't
get it
right and you didn't just luckily fall
into a group I didn't have that I grew
up in a town that had been economically
depressed for a century
I grew up in a town that there it was so
survival mindset but also very
aggressive and competitive there there
wasn't a whole lot of talk about these
things and I had to go find and build it
I had to start going to personal
development seminars I had to engage
with higher Achievers I had to look for
people who had fulfillment in their
lives no matter what they were doing and
I had to seek them out and I made that a
choice I made that a decision I said I'm
going to create an awesome group of
people be around my life I don't know
how but I'm going to do networking I'm
gonna do volunteering I'm gonna ask to
be around people and I'm going to get
mentors and I'm I'm going to make sure
that I surround myself with people who
care about life
who want to live meaningful and
fulfilling Lives who want to lead who
want to make a difference and I can't
think a single person at all in my
entire life today you know after that
was that decision was 25 years ago for
me
I can't think of a single person who I
have a consistent or recurring
communication with in my entire life
who isn't like that now
every person to a person
to a t every person I interact with has
some sense of that or they don't get in
my world
it doesn't mean I'm unfair or discount
people it just means I'm not going to
let that stuff into my head
and I don't say that I'm perfect I say
it took me 20 years like I said that's
gonna be a goal I'm gonna get there
and I want you to have that goal like
the people around you should be so
fulfilled and so happy and grateful for
their lives
and you gotta find that
you got to lead that you got to
cultivate that you got to talk about
that I think fulfillment should be a
topic that people talk about every
single month of their life
if you're in relationship with someone
ask your spouse your partner hey
do you feel fulfilled
and just hold that space
if they don't feel fulfilled
ask why
get to know them understand what they're
really looking for encourage them to go
in the direction that will bring them
that fulfillment
encourage them you know at the end of a
bad day when you hear them say send
separate sentence of negative self-talk
or meaning after meaning
that's catastrophic
terrible negative awful
be that encourager
be that person who helps them maybe
think about or become more aware of that
self-talk or those labels or that
meaning you can do it without judgment
but you can also be committed to
building the circle of influence that
you deserve in your life at this stage
of your life you have to be
conscientious about it you got to get at
it because when those people around you
are living a life of impact and meaning
and fulfillment it lifts you up I have
down days and then I talk to somebody in
my circle and it's like whoa it just
kind of resets my brain a little bit
and I go oh I've been speaking negative
oh I've been thinking small or I would
and all right okay yeah I am lucky I am
blessed oh my gosh let's go Brandon and
I get back on because sometimes you will
drown in your own discouragement and it
is your circle of influence the people
around you people in your network who
can help draw you out of that faster and
that is something to be grateful for
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five practice
emotional regulation practice emotional
regulation
practice emotional regulation
and we're going to talk about what that
means because here's what happens
you have two choices in a conflict
situation you have emotional regulation
or you have emotional Contagion
you'd better make that choice
consciously
emotional regulation or emotional
Contagion
so what is emotional contagion emotional
contagion is that part of us that we are
hardwired to do which is mimic or act
out respond to
someone else's emotions
it's how when you walk up to a group of
three people who are sad you start to
feel sad
it's how a an eight-month year old baby
Mel Abraham will will when you smile at
the eight month year old and you and
they they smile back they can't help it
what's happening there
it's in your brain in your prefrontal
cortex these things called your mirror
neurons
that make you or in your cortex it helps
you
want to mimic other people and match
their emotions
it's why when someone yawns you yawn
it's why when someone gets super angry
you feel your blood go up
it's automatic it's impulsive and it is
hard wired
until we run a new program over so many
times
that that gets stampined maybe it
doesn't go away but it gets dampened
right
emotional regulation however is a
conscious choice
to sense and feel the emotions coming up
and to regulate them appropriately
for my intentions or the situation
it means you take the reins of your
emotions and your feelings and your
behaviors it means you're personally
responsible for it and that's hard
because if you heard me teach on this
before there's a big difference between
emotions and feelings I talked about it
in a daily fire
that your emotions psychologically so
when we talk about emotions in in my
field of practice whether it is in what
actually doesn't matter what the field
of practice if it's in Psychology if
it's in coaching work emotions are
automatic physical
impulsive
and very difficult
to dictate
their extremity
very it's just like emotions tend to
happen
feelings however
think about feelings are kind of like
the wake of an emotion
but you get to apply meaning to it
feelings you have much more control over
it's a lingering effect of an emotion
emotion in most at least most
neuroscience and and most studies of
physiology of emotion and emotion is
actually pretty quick to come up and go
right emotion can come in maybe 60
seconds 90 seconds sometimes two three
minutes in the extreme
but the emotion itself tends to pass and
now the brain is starting to label it
attach meaning to it decide what does
this mean what does this mean for me is
this safe is this bad a lot of mental
processing is actually taken over and
now it's creating a lasting feeling rule
number six take a turn I like the phrase
take turns it means you take a turn
many of You Are So Silent in what you
really think feel need expect deserve
want
many of you never speak up for yourself
many of you get bulldozed every single
conversation and you keep blaming them
for bulldozing
versus speaking up
many people do not participate in
conflict
they just listen
they get mad passive aggressive
they quit
they Stonewall
they refuse to set boundaries they
refuse to ideate
and they just get more and more
disconnected disengaged
stop participating and if you've ever
been in a situation like that with
someone else it drives you mad
it's just like I can't believe they're
stonewalling me I can't believe they're
not participating
and it gets very very upsetting for me
that's a big one for me when someone
like I know that triggers me when they
won't participate
in a respectful process I gotta breathe
I gotta move I gotta self-talk baby
emotional regulation because that one
will get me going
but I see it all the time
and so take turns means you take your
turn
and you set up the space that they're
gonna make theirs
you ask the questions to draw them out
you give them the platform to speak
you express what you need to express
you take a beat and you don't wait
listen this is so important if you want
to be a great communicator
after you've expressed what you needed
to express
please don't expect them
to comply
accept
validate or say yes to what you just
said
think about this way you just got to
take your turn
now they get to take their turn
then you get to move towards resolution
but what you just said was not the
resolution
what you just said was your piece
you took your turn
now they get to take their turn
in taking their turn their turn is not
set up they have to agree or comply
they just get their turn
and when they get their turn you listen
when they get their turn you reflect
that's the key
most people when you take your turn you
expect compliance
and that's where the whole thing falls
apart in conflict
that they have to do it your way all the
time immediately
oh man that sucks I know you've been
there before but
the reality is most people think they've
been there before but don't realize they
put others there before too
and we have to take ownership of that
again this is not Brandon Richard being
perfect to you I've done this a million
times accidentally I mean I don't know
how many conversations I've had where I
feel like I've I've made a great
argument and they should just go yes
and then they don't I'm like how can you
not agree with that and then I argue
with them and it devolves from there
instead of builds from there because I
didn't make sure they took their turn
now that I have vented or I've expressed
now they get an equal part
to share back and when they share back
even if they didn't agree with me yet
and I'm I just wanted to say yes I've
got to go okay Brandon oh fine
feelings interests needs expectations
listen for those reflect those back
because if they feel heard right now
then we can move to resolution
so key taking turns please do me a favor
make sure you take your turn rule number
seven be real and authentic our job and
our relationships is to create
real authentic
caring
interactions real authentic caring write
it down real authentic caring
real means that we are being who we
really are in that relationship
right we are being real with that person
we're speaking our real thoughts
feelings dreams desires needs
we understand and hear their real
thoughts feelings desires needs and
dreams we validate it we appreciate it
we are acknowledging it that's being
real with one another right we're
meeting each other as two people who are
separate we're coming together creating
a real connection based on actual
honesty and trust that comes from
sharing one of those real thoughts
feelings desires dreams needs
that's real
authentic
authentic means oh this relationship is
unique to us
so often we're taught in the modern
world authenticity is about us because
we all think of authenticity now as like
social media am I showing up real in my
social media but in real life in in
family Dynamics or sociology
authenticity is about the relationship
it's it's I am authentic with myself
in relationship with my sister we have
an authentic relationship and my
relationship with my mom is different we
have an authentic relationship an
authentic relationship with my mother
means different things than authentic
relationship with my sister as an
example right each person you have a
team you have a team if you treat each
person on the team exactly the same
because you're always authentic it
that's not an authentic relationship an
authentic relationship is that
relationship with them is real and
unique to them it's authentic with that
person
that's what we're talking about here
um we've got to be able to have on top
of this realness or this authenticity
this the sense of that there's a depth
or an intimacy in that relationship
depth would be like oh I know things
about this person
intimacy could mean the same thing which
means there's a depth there that can be
physical as well but I think depth or
Intimacy in sharing with one another is
really important I think most people
don't have a feeling relationships
because they don't have deep
relationships
they're always talking about surface
things they're talking about what's on
TV they're talking about the weather
they're talking about what's in the
media they're talking about comparison
to other people but they never talk
about the meaning of life
I would say you you barely know a person
until you've talked about the meaning of
life with someone
because what do you really know if
you're not connected or understanding
what their sense of purpose is or where
they draw fulfillment or meaning from so
this whole conversation we're having
today if you had conversations like this
with your family think about how deep
are those relationships would be I know
some of you are laughing right now
because you can imagine never having
this conversation with your family I
totally understand but I think it's
important that we say okay
if I want to have a great relationships
they've got to be real they've got to be
trusting they've got to be intimate
they've got to be deeper and the more I
would say this I was something with
Denise actually about this topic this
morning
and she was like when she thinks about
meeting and filming her first go-to is
relationships
first go to
because you know if the people around
you
don't ever sense fulfillment
if the people around you
don't imbue moments with meaning
then now you're left to do all the hard
work and if you haven't done personal
development work before what ends up
happening is you kind of just take
what's given to you
and I think it's important that we
realize the people we surround ourselves
with should be people who understand
life's meaning who are seeking it out
people who want to feel fulfilled do
good things be Role Models because those
people Lift us up those people Recon has
anyone had an interaction with somebody
in the last year or two who reminded you
about the blessings or the importance of
Life rule number eight remain objective
this is a person who's you know creating
a situation here they can get not good
so I want to improve the situation and I
want to build a relationship this is my
spouse it's my partner I've committed
and sworn to God that I will honor and
protect and love and serve and
care for and be there with and for this
person
okay
um
let me take another deep breath
let me not react
let me start managing myself talk
immediately
be here
take deep breaths
listen Brendan
be here take deep breaths listen Brendan
it's not react it's not scream it's just
be here
listen react
it's emotional regulation
my friend John Gray he wrote this book
called minor from Mars Women Are from
Venus and whether or not you like that
metaphor whether that's old school now
in the modern era one of the things he
said to me the one time was so good he
said I was talking about he was asking
about conflicts I had
in my relationship and how I approach
him what I said to myself and everything
else and he goes he literally interrupts
me describing what I think is my coping
mechanism he goes Brennan do you wear a
watch
yeah okay yeah I wear a watch
he goes here's what I want you to do
next time
your partner is saying something that
you don't like
or they're venting to you and you don't
want to hear it and it's going to cause
you to get angry or mad or to solve or
to react next time all I want you to do
is as they're talking make great eye
contact
take a lot of deep breaths
really quickly glance at your watch
don't let them see it
and just wait
20 minutes as you make eye contact and
you breathe
I said 20 minutes why he goes because by
the end of 20 minutes they're out of gas
they vented they've frustrated they got
it out and you were there listening
being attentive not solving her problem
not telling her she's wrong
you just let her go for 20 minutes man
I go that's it he goes
you gotta watch
like oh my gosh and you know what it's
real it totally works
for the guys looking for the tactic shut
up listen
give her some time to talk this works in
almost every relationship every conflict
situation the other person really needs
to vent and talk it out and if you can
understand they're coming from a place
where they are triggered or traumatized
where they're defensive did you know the
more people tend to talk and if a person
just sits there with them
the more they talk it out the more they
actually calm themselves down
right therapists will know this right
they just sit and listen sometimes
right very rarely with another person
who's holding a good space there
will someone keep ramping it up you've
got to practice emotional regulation
as soon as you feel it come up breathe
maybe move around a little bit go for a
walk or pause the conversation to go you
know what I'm I'm feeling really upset
or triggered right now can I can I take
a Beat Can I just I'm gonna do a lap
around the house I'll be right back is
that okay can we just hold it for a
second I really want to do a good job
for you in this conversation I hear this
is important for you but I'm all kind of
frazzled can I come right back and be
more centered with you
oh we're allowed to say that yeah oh
okay you go around take a deep breath
now you come back centered more calm you
breathed you moved and remember the
self-talk
remember the self-taught the self-talk
is what generates the feeling
after the emotion passes so what are we
saying to ourselves what are we stating
what are the thoughts going through our
head being thoughtful about that
mine again I already told you improve
the situation build the relationship
improve the situation build the
relationship rule number nine allow
yourself to transform I don't know if
you've picked up on it yet
but the world is turning a new chapter
you should too
I know if you picked up on it but this
is a time of ripe transition and
transformation
allow that for yourself
yeah maybe you screwed up last year in
the business maybe you screwed up four
years ago maybe you did something that
you feel like was Unforgivable
in this moment right here in Your Heart
of Heart in the universe
you gotta clean slate
and it is time to start adjusting
from who you were
to who you desire to become
you need to get off the guilt train
and on the becoming train
that old story that chapter closed the
new story is a bunch of blank pages a
lot of self-acceptance
happens in the orientation towards the
future having something to look forward
to deciding to become somebody or
something that you will be proud of
versus sitting there and going I'm
terrible because of last year that year
that year like ruminating on the old
Stories versus building the new one what
are we gonna do
when you feel like you're trapped in a
negative route it's often because you
are replaying past old Stories versus
building the new one
it's a new chapter time can I get an
amen on a weekday with anybody it's like
it is a new chapter time it is a get on
the becoming train it is a like our
self-acceptance is revitalized when you
say oh I'm remaking myself
this time I will be intentional this
time I will do a supportive people this
time I will be disciplined and practiced
about it and all of a sudden you start
feeling better about yourself you want
to feel bad about yourself ruminate on
all the old bad things that happen to
you and all the old bad things you did
before
this is why it's so critical to do
personal development work because it
always leans you towards the future
right it always helps you go oh wait I
just got some blank slates here I got
some new chapters here I got some ways
to revitalize myself as soon as yourself
right as soon as your mind acknowledges
that you are building again
something changes a new energy comes
from within and all of a sudden the next
thing can happen you can be congruent
with that vision of yourself
you cast a new vision of yourself and
you take the habits you do the practices
that help you be congruent with becoming
that self and all of a sudden with
greater congruence towards a future self
your confidence comes back up
it's the easiest way to shift somebody
out of that old mentality or those old
feelings or that low self-esteem into a
higher gear
it's about oh
okay I can acknowledge and I can
appreciate and I can accept that the
life that I've lived has happened
I can accept that everything's not
perfect
I can accept I'm not perfect and neither
are they but I can also accept
that right now in this moment
I can have hope
I can accept that right now in this
moment
I can write some new ideas now I can
accept right now in this moment that
tomorrow I can start changing my mindset
to be happy even if my circumstances
aren't yet there
I was a happy
exuberant enthusiastic loving person
at a time where I was constantly in
physically fights I was broke
and I had almost no hope
for a future that would become what what
my life became like
and yet I decided okay I need
to start living into the vision of who I
can become and who I feel called to
become
because who I feel called to become
isn't this person laying in bed feeling
bad about himself all day even though I
had plenty of reasons to feel bad about
myself I will never say to you you don't
have any reasons to feel bad about
yourself I love spiritual teachers who
can teach that I can't do it but I love
when they do
what I might suggest is like hey
let's just accept ourselves I can accept
that you did bad things in the past
I can also accept that maybe you'll
choose today to shift gears and to start
that forward lean to building the Future
character of who you can really become
that's the hope and the promise and the
beauty and the potential of
self-improvement
you know that's the stuff that we
understand change the world in the world
of philosophy all of a sudden you know
you had from stoicism to Christianity
that all of a sudden you know Rousseau
talking about the idea that we have
Liberty and the ability to improve
ourselves oh wait a minute that's a
hopeful Revolution
and that's sometimes what we need that's
sometimes what we need and also I want
to remind you sometimes that means
getting around more supportive people
sometimes that means hiring yourself a
coach so they can monitor your mindset
and help you build sometimes that means
getting a therapy so they can heal the
old stuff whatever it means it means
that you have the opportunity to do it
and what I encourage all of you
set as a goal
to feel good about yourself skin manual
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is wow your
relationships make sure by the end of
this year
you have wowed your relationships
wowing your relationships means today
you sit down
you identify the most important
relationships in your life and you ask
the question
how can I wow that person
this year
and it doesn't mean you have to do
anything extravagant and buy them big
gifts or take them on big trips though
you might have one or two people gonna
do that with
it just means usually here's what Wows
people
appreciation
a written card
some encouraging audio texts
a nice email
more frequent phone calls
it's simple
it's simple wow the most important
people in your life by the end of this
year now I know you might already have a
good track record maybe you had a great
summer with somebody carried on
see it through finish this year strong
in your relationships remember long-term
healthy relationships are a secret to
longevity and life satisfaction so who's
somebody that you could reach out to
with some appreciation some love some
encouragement I put this as part of my
morning routine some of you guys know is
I send five encouraging audio texts
every single morning
to the persons in my personal life
usually sometimes in my professional
life my peer Network or my team usually
for me it's my personal network of
friends and family who who've encouraged
me throughout the years and I want to be
that source for them
and so who could you wow
by the end of this year
maybe you've had a a tough year like
lots of couples did with your partner
your spouse
and you've kind of been struggling a
little bit and right now it's been all
about the blame and the negativity
and maybe you guys aren't even gonna
make it
but could you still do something to wow
that person
I think that when we remember that we
signed up for the relationships we're in
in our life
by and large
that you know okay I signed it up for
this I'm going to end this well or I'm
going to wow this person or I'm going to
take it as an obligation or
responsibility to make their life better
like it's it it's my job I feel in my
marriage to make our life better
to constantly surprise my wife to
constantly give and be generous into
that relationship even when it's busy
even when it's hard with little things
and I can't say I'm great at it but it's
always on my intention radar it's every
day I'm thoughtful about it every day I
try to do something and it doesn't take
much I mean the joy of my wife gets when
I pick up or clean up is amazing you
know so we all have different ways and
most people don't need you to do some
big extravagant thing it's the things
that they need it's you know their love
language it's their priority their
preference even if you don't like it you
know even if that's not the meal you
want to eat make them that meal that day
maybe maybe you've had a hard time and
you know you could hold it against them
maybe today you let it go
and you approach them with open arms and
open spirit
to try to repair
you have to learn to practice presence
practice presence being here fully in
the moment alive vibrant or at least
attentive right snapping your brain out
of that reactive like uh go with the
flow mode to no and being here
that oldest advice in all of personal
development about presence and awareness
about being with the flow about being in
the moment there's every spiritual
tradition has taught it as being Central
to human happiness and connection
this has been stolen from us because of
this
I really believe I I I'm stunned when I
hang out with people that they can't be
present for three minutes without
wanting to scroll through something I
mean they can't be I mean even four or
five minutes they can't do it anymore
because they have trained themselves
with millions of swipes
to be not present
and I believe that meaning and
fulfillment
um they become too fleeting
when we haven't learned to be really
present
and I think that's important learning to
be really fully present
and pulling that from ourselves there's
plenty of times I mean if you saw my
schedule you're like how do you get
present I'm like I've trained myself
otherwise I can just be pulled in the
next thing there's always a million
things going on around me and I have to
learn to just zoom right in and be here
with you
you have to teach yourself to do that
too
because the more days that Blur by the
less sense of meaning or fulfillment you
have you can be busy
but the days don't Blur by
right I'm incredibly busy I'm actually
this last two years I can't believe how
busy we got but during that time present
forcing myself each day to get present
so I can recognize and appreciate those
little moments so I can create the
connection with other people
so that I can sense that spiritual
aliveness of being here now versus
hoping one day to arrive to something
and that that practice of cultivating
presence of I would say and I know
people don't like when I use this phrase
but demanding presence I demand of
myself to be present I because I know
when I'm not I'm like Brendan get
present okay so I might bounce in place
take 10 deep breaths just to reset my
brain and my body
and that 10d maybe you do it right now
with me just stand up wherever you're at
bounce in place a little bit take 10
deep breaths
re-center yourself to the moment and
keep going
and that way you can observe life many
people they'll work their whole career
then they'll retire and they'll retire
and they'll finally be like oh wow look
at the color of the trees this is
amazing wow life looks pretty good and
they didn't even see it for five six
years they missed all of it even though
they were amidst all of it they just
missed it you have to teach yourself to
be with it to be here meaning and
fulfillment is so much as much as we can
Define it and have a destiny mindset we
can feel it
like I do it for like if I have a great
dinner with Denise like things go great
we just have a nice conversation I'll
walk away and I'll like be like putting
things away and just literally thinking
my mind
what a blessing
God I made it
thank you so much for this blessing to
be here with my wife what a great day
what an amazing moment we just had you
know what years later I'm going to
cherish that dinner
simple as that it's what we say to
ourselves
in the minute and after the minute that
really defines how we feel over the long
term isn't true
I mean the little moments if you can
celebrate them be there for them give
thanks for them I believe the more you
give thanks for the moments in your life
the more meaning you find
the more you give thanks for the moments
in your life the more you feel fulfilled
even if you feel years away even if the
next big thing is out there it's okay
right now you're feeling it that's what
presence is it's about feeling the day
more you hear me teach this now for what
20 years like you have to learn to feel
life
if we don't feel it then what's it about
and you're not just going to suddenly
one day feel it you know because you
drank a bunch of coffee maybe you are
but you're you're gonna you're gonna
imagine me uncapping one day you're just
gonna you're gonna teach yourself to
feel the day and feel the moments more
you're going to observe more you're
going to breathe more
you'd have more intention and as you
learn to feel the day when someone says
hey you feel fulfilled about your life
you're like I do
because you are filling life
with presence when you fill life with
presence you feel full filled
it takes an active participation on your
point you're not just gonna show up one
day and feel fulfilled you have to fill
the day
with those senses of gratitude and
meaning and really
um I would say connection
if you don't do that I promise the days
just Blur by and the more they Blur by
the more you just stack on everybody
else's reactions needs desires drives
distractions their meaning and one day
you show up and you're just
you're really just a bag of everyone
else's intentions and needs and drives
and labels and meanings
and in that place
you're not autonomous
in that place
you don't get to experience that
individual sense of meaning and
fulfillment we've talked about from the
very beginning because you didn't take
the time to Define it consistently
enough time to go out and volunteer
my very favorite way to change someone's
life is to turn them into a volunteer I
don't care what they volunteer for but
go volunteer they will change everything
because who does volunteering purposeful
humans you know so it's my favorite way
to improve your social life if you're
not around purposeful people volunteer
you'll meet more so people more
intentional people more present people
more appreciative people
but also if you are struggling in any of
your relationships please watch the
relationship trainings or courses in
growth day because they've found that
just one negative or hurtful
relationship in your life
can dramatically decrease your sense of
purpose in life
your overall sense of purpose by one
person and we know that to be true in
your career right you have one bad boss
they can ruin the whole company for you
well that's true in our personal lives
too
one negative hurtful person consistently
in your life tends to decrease your
sense of purpose in life
by three points out of ten
so meaning let's say on a scale of 10 0
to 10 you feel life is purposeful and
you're really connected to it ten you
feel totally purposeful totally
connected zero you have none
let's say you're as level seven
having one negative or hurtful person
recurring in your life takes that seven
down to a four
that's why
that's saying don't suffer fools
is a good one
if you got somebody who's negative or
hurtful it's time to do the relationship
work to either improve that situation
with that person
help them get assistance or helper
coaching or exit that situation
if you can't do any of those then you've
got to find a tribe or a community over
here that you build up
that meets those needs
and I think that's important because
sometimes people say well Brandon my
mother she's terrible and I hate having
around I'm like okay well you can't
necessarily replace your mama maybe you
can limit time there but sometimes
people can't they're they're caregiving
as an example
and like okay well then outside that
house we've got to develop the
relationships that provide you with that
sense
where it's lacking there in that
particular relationship
and so I think that's really really
important just try
and what I mean by try is try with other
people again
I I watch people talk at lunch they're
not really trying to be engaged they're
not really there they just and it's
great that they're comfortable with
themselves but they've kind of they're
going through the motions
and very few things ever happen amazing
when people are two people are just
going through the motions because our
default going through the motions unless
it's imbued by like challenge or
presence or vibrancy usually our default
is homeostasis of just like yeah
and that is not very attractive okay
that is not something gets people's
attention when people get people's
attention is when you put an effort to
listen to them to be with them to be
present with them to change the energy
between the two of you for you to spark
something stop waiting for good energy
to come into your life and start
generating great energy and you'll feel
the difference try with your energy
again right really pay attention to
people be present with them they'll feel
that you're trying and they'll
appreciate it I'm not saying faking
right so if it's not authentic and real
don't do it but you must try more often
to show up as your best self into
conversations and to try and pull out
the best of others I think the most sexy
thing in a person ever is someone who's
trying to pull out the best energy from
you right whether they're trying to pull
out the flirtation of you or pull out
the joy of you or the Gratitude of you
or that positive range of emotions from
you that's pretty sexy so try to bring
out the best of others I think it's
really important to stay in your job in
a relationship and I don't mean by your
your employment right you can quit your
job but don't quit the relationship but
what's your job in a relationship it's
to love
and it's so easy to forget that because
we get mad at somebody and they didn't
run the task or empty the garbage or
take out the dishes wait I think I got
it backwards but they forgot something
and we get mad at them we forget our job
there is to love and if you're really
going to choose love over choosing your
past or going to choose love over fear
or hurt or pain or choose love or being
you know right
then you're gonna start to find
something switches in that relationship
and it's a good thing see most people
aren't choosing love they're choosing
fear most people aren't choosing love
they're choosing hurt and because of
that over and over and over again that
simple choice in the relationship
they're not approaching the relationship
with the intention of love right if you
can approach your relationship with the
intention of love to say look I'm just
going to keep bringing joy and love and
acceptance and compassion and empathy
and vibrancy and sensuality to this
relationship and you're always doing
that more often than you're bringing the
negative stuff that relationship will
suddenly start to turn positive it will
get easier as you change your intentions
to be more geared towards love that's
your job stay in your job in the
relationship to love this person to make
their day to surprise them to care for
them stop asking so much what you're
getting from the relationship and how
they've done you all wrong and start
asking what have you been doing right
what have you been doing to add value
love energy vibrancy sensuality to their
life what have you been doing to love
them ask the question how can you
deliver more love to your partner and to
the world and you might start to
experience what we call the charge life
your life matters my life matters those
people you hate out on the internet
their life matters
that what happens is we get so myopic
into our own world of okay is the little
thing I'm doing today does that matter
there's my you know the the this this
one thing I did does that make me feel
fulfilled and complete as a person and
we lack an overall life philosophy and
overall life philosophy
that we have defined our lives and the
context of humanity as meaningful
I know this might be too academic for
some people and that's why I use the
word or the phrase a destiny mindset if
you have lost that feeling
that says I have an opportunity to make
a difference while I am here You've Lost
That connection with what I'm calling a
destiny mindset
a destiny mindset and I know some people
will take a destiny mindset that's like
oh you know I got to see myself on a
cover of a magazine I'm like bad no less
people on covers of magazines you don't
feel a sense of meaning or fulfillment
in their life
it's not an external thing it's an
internal or intrinsic thing
that I just feel called I feel that my
life is leading to something important I
feel honored or privileged or grateful
that I can make a difference in the
future
and that make a difference in the future
thing
is a overall life philosophy that is
connected to Destiny
and I hope you start thinking about that
because you know what sometimes you wake
up in the freaking morning and you pull
this thing out don't you you pull out
your phone in the morning and what do
you do you start scrolling through
everybody else's stuff everybody else's
agenda everybody else's life and you get
trapped into the myopic looking at that
comment and getting sad or upset about
it you get trapped into small things of
Life the tasks the emails the responses
and all of a sudden you've been pulled
into this tiny little myopic to-do list
part of your life and you forgot the
being part of your life
you want to feel more meaning in your
life start your day with that Destiny
mindset can you show me somewhere
something that you look at every day
that opens up your mind and reminds you
to get out of that little myopic brain
that we all have that's just focused
right here
because if you never look at the bigger
vision of life
it's hard to ever feel a deep sense of
meaning or fulfillment when people have
clarity about their future
and clarity about their purpose it tends
to come in different categories here
okay so let me give you some of those
categories
first is yourself
I know that sounds like no doubt Brandon
but this is yourself in terms of your
identity
this is yourself in terms of who you are
becoming
and this is yourself
in terms of your self-worth
okay I'll cover those three elements
here in a second
self
in regards to your identity
who am I
self in terms of who you are becoming
who do I believe I am meant to become or
do I desire to become
and self in terms of self-worth
am I
Worthy
these questions
make you either feel connected as a
purposeful being
or they make you feel terrible
and so let's explore them your identity
I always ask this in my seminars if
you've never done this work with me it's
from one of my other books called the
charge
and the charge being like the amp like
the battery pack like you know the the
subtitle was activating the 10 human
drives that make you feel alive look is
called the charge
and one of the things I started asking
people to do
and high performance work was to share
with me to generate and share with me
what are the three words
that would define
the best of Who You Are
today
like if you had to describe yourself
like let's say you went on speed dating
and you sat down uh across from someone
and the question was okay share the
three best parts of you
and with using one word describe that
now it's kind of like that right it's
like what's the three like if I had to
describe the best of who I am in three
words what would my three words be
what are your three words like what are
your three words that that is the best
of Who You Are
or if you struggle with that the three
words that would describe the best of
who you want to be
I want to make sure
that you have your three words and I
want your three words on a board or I
want the three words on your mirror or I
want the three words next to your
computer and every day you look at those
three words again today I'm going to be
this
at midday am I being this
at the end of the day was I that
we need to develop a purposeful sense of
being and remind ourselves of it I do
not expect other people
to think or feel or experience life like
me
it just isn't there I don't think my
team members should think like me or are
like me I don't think that my spouse is
anything like me she has her own
Universe of emotions and feelings you're
very different to my trust me way
different I we think I think my family
my friends is like there's no for me uh
demand
that they
think like me doesn't mean I don't get
frustrated that we don't have a good
relationship or I don't like their
communication or I don't like something
they said or I feel neglected or hurt we
all have those things the question is
over a period of time
do you have depth and closeness in that
relationship
I promise there's a ton of things
Denise my spouse she would say that she
doesn't like about how I think or how I
experience the world
and I would say the same about her
but the question isn't do we like
everything that we say the question is
is there depth and closeness and
Intimacy in our relationship
and that only happens if enough times
you realize the person is different than
you
different preferences
different hopes different needs
like I'm I'm probably needier than my
wife is in terms of like emotional stuff
I just the way I am and you might be
different than your spouse your friend
your dad your mom someone who raised you
and if you're trying to cram the world
with this expectation that they gotta be
think and behave exactly like you
that is where there is a ripping of that
relationship
you got to let other people have their
own life
and the more you try to control their
life the more misery you have
a lot of mental health is letting other
people live their life
not trying to control everything
you know what mental illness is when you
feel like you must control everything
what do you find meaning in
is there something you love you could
give a few more hours to is there
someone you love you could give a few
more hours to
is there an interest or hobby a passion
that you just love doing and maybe you
know what it doesn't add up to the bank
account
I just get you on the cover of the
magazines
but it makes life worthwhile
you feel better you feel a greater sense
of fulfillment from life because you're
living life doing things and being a
person that you love
I think ultimately all meaning and
fulfillment all roads somehow lead back
this topic of love
might not have all the answers on that
one that might be something for you to
journal about today
how does love connect to your sense
of meaning and fulfillment in life
that might mean you live with love
meaning you are loving-hearted towards
other people
it might mean how you treat other people
it might be the things that you do it
might be your life philosophy
however you define it I promise you my
friends love
that's the answer somewhere our social
realm is incredibly purposeful
most importantly is this and you all
know this as Strivers here in growth day
but I think this is so critical
you've got to be around purposeful
people
you got to be around purposeful people
if you feel like the people around you
aren't as purple as they should send
them to growthday.com you know it's like
maybe they need a little training a lot
of people need training
on this topic just like my friend I told
you about the woman I was coaching who
she'd never been trained to ask the
question what would make her feel
fulfilled most people never been trained
on purpose either
but getting around
striving
giving
generous kind compassionate High
performing people will completely make
you feel different about life
I think about my friendships and the
people in my life they got a lot of
purpose
and and it doesn't mean they have this
end game it means they're living
purposeful lives with great intention
and appreciation and presence
so they're awesome to be around
do you have five people who are awesome
to be around in your life
like awesome
and purposeful
if not time to meet them literally today
somebody a friend of mine reached out
about a situation going on in the world
that he wanted to support and was asking
me for support and it was a cause I
don't know that much about
but I know he loves this and this is
near and dear his Tweets in his heart
and I can learn from it and so I support
it
I think of all the time like what what
does my wife love oh she loves that you
know that thing she loves design she
loves that show she loves these people
she loves this experience okay okay how
can I serve that up because if you serve
up what other people love or you honor
it respect it cheer it on support it in
some way the depth of that relationship
becomes tangible and now there's energy
there because they feel the three things
that everybody needs to feel they feel
understood they feel validated they feel
celebrated to live their own life
so if you can understand other people
if you can validate them if you can
celebrate what they like and what they
love their obsessions versus making them
have to do what you do
life is so much easier
I'll take an example uh years ago Denise
and I started working together and uh we
had a a podcast the time hvx podcast I
think we did maybe like 10 20 episodes
maybe I can't remember what it was and
it was just super clear that this was
not something that she loved
and we didn't love doing it really
together the way that we thought we
would it was like
let's call that
so we just ended it
didn't worry about what people thought
didn't worry about the business didn't
work I was like oh that's not something
we love doing together let's not do that
there's things that I love in my life
totally not her Jam things that she
loves totally not my jam
and we cheer it on
we support it and increase that depth
and that closeness of relationship and
if you don't have that with other people
guess what you don't get to complain
it's your job to have that difficult
conversation it's your job to bring it
up to make a plan to work through it
even if that takes weeks or years to
shift your Mutual behaviors in that
relationship don't give up on the person
just because they don't get you
because guess what it's not their job to
get you it's not your job to get but if
you want to have a graceful deep
intimate connected relationship it's now
time what do they love and how can I
support that how can I let them be their
thing let them you know buy their flag
be their weirdness and cheer them on in
whatever way that makes sense because it
makes them happy
what does your spouse your partner your
co-workers love to do
you know uh in my companies I never am
like you have to be this role like what
do you like to do first always like what
what do you like well I don't like this
I'm gonna do that I'm like oh well let's
try to figure out a plan to get you more
towards that
and that's always been my thing oh you
lifetime you want to do more of that
okay and that makes a team feel heard
and seen and recognized and if they
complain if they don't like something
they're just like oh can I shift that
for them because that's their vibe
you got to figure that out I can have a
terrible day and at the end of the day I
can go okay two years ago here's how I
would have dealt with that terrible day
today how can I improve how I deal with
this terrible day
it doesn't mean you don't have terrible
days anymore does it
it doesn't mean you're not tired it
doesn't mean you don't get stressed
doesn't mean you don't get frustrated
what it means is
you have the intention
to ask oh
how can I improve how I'm dealing with
this
how can I like what have you ever been
in a relationship where you and your
partner your spouse have the same fight
over and over and over and over and over
and over again it's literally the same
bite over and over and over and over
again no it's literally the same fight
over and over you ever had that
that what's lacking is somebody there is
lacking the accountability and the
consistent action to say how can I
improve this
how can I do it what's happened is it's
turned into a blame game right
this person's responsible not me
no accountability no action I don't have
to improve it you improve it you broke
it you cheated you're the bad one you're
the one bringing this up
and all of a sudden you you blame blame
blame no accountability I don't have to
change no action if both couples get
into that that's where couples therapy
has to happen because they're both in
the blame game they both taken the
accountability off they believe the lie
that you know relationships have to be
50 50 equal no relationships actually
mean 100 100. you're 100 you're
responsible for yourself I'm 100
responsible myself and it takes a
hundred percent to keep improving this
thing and making a better year over year
I think that's what people forget it's
not like huge dramatic shifts always
need to happen what has to happen for
most people to change awareness
acceptance and accountability
and then just small consistent actions
to improve
right it's like it can be that can be so
tactical and tangible I think of like
you know my career as a coach I I just
try to get better every session
it doesn't mean I'm always actually
better every session it's my intention
I'm gonna get better
every session with this client will get
better sometimes it feels like it goes
two steps back luckily it's three steps
forward
at some point and so I don't pretend
that every day is a bright shiny happy
place I just pretend that every day it's
possible to improve to improve my
reaction to improve my energy to improve
how I treat this person to improve how I
stay congruent
right it is that constant desire
that constant intention to have
purposeful living and no one has
purposeful intention or purposeful
living and decides you know I don't want
to improve today
you can accept yourself and still want
to improve today
right the Dalai Lama can be fully
accepting
of himself
but he can also want to improve his
meditative practice right we all have
that impulse to grow improve develop
Mastery personal growth and purpose is
something we cultivated on a very
regular basis otherwise you lose touch
with it just like most people say I lost
my motivation I go you didn't lose your
motivation you lost the practice of
paying attention to the things that
matter to you
and using your mind to rev you up for
those things
that's all
you started going through the motions
and so you lost the motivation
you can still do the same thing but
instead of just going through it
unconsciously bring conscious intention
by bringing purposeful being to a thing
it changes
well as you learn to make being a
purposeful being happen on a more
regular basis I promise you can shift
that's the hopeful message for today I
know sometimes you watch something like
this you're not in a good mood you don't
feel good there's been a travesty
something's going on in the world you
don't like and your day is just kind of
like all over the place
but that's why we're here
it's got to do it's like constantly
doing the work I would love for you to
all type this in either your journal or
the chat or the comments right now I
love constantly doing the work
actually write it down I love constantly
doing work you have to teach yourself I
love constantly doing the work
I get an argument with my wife I'm like
oh I love constantly doing the work
like you have to keep generating the
ambition and the J engagement enjoyment
of doing the personal development work
you know I walk out of a conflict or an
argument with somebody and I have to go
recenter myself I'm like okay Brendan
chance to learn buddy
what do you got to learn
how can next time be better
how do I really want to show up
how can I repair this
how can we improve the situation next
time How Could I approach it differently
what can I watch for next time to make
it better
let me try
you got this next time Brennan
be graceful for today you got this next
time a little more intention okay here
we go
[Music]
over and over and over giving yourself
the grace to learn to to enter the next
situation more intentionally
tough of purpose
[Music]
for those of you who are really
struggling to like meet
high quality people from your
perspective
I can't recommend enough that you get
involved with some local organizations
that are non-profit based and you start
attending more fundraisers more acts of
service and I know some of you go I
don't I don't have anything I don't have
money to contribute maybe or I don't
have you know I don't know what I want
to do I'm like I don't care go to a
bunch of them and you'll learn what you
like
and I will also say this I know I've
been saying this for years I I've been a
dead drum a little bit here
but when you go to a fundraiser
or you go to a volunteer event do you
know who ghosts those
like you go to black tie event like a
fundraiser as an example do you know who
goes there
the most successful High achieving
positive wealthy influential people in
that particular community
people who have something to give and in
their spirit in their heart says I I
play this role in this community where
I'm going to make a difference here
as I've met throughout the years I met
either doing the work of contribution or
literally on a non-profit board or at a
fundraiser
because that striving Community who
wants to make a difference
I can't I can't share with that but
here's the thing whether you go do that
or you don't
the people who are closest to you if you
want to make a difference with them
if you want to deepen that relationship
find a way to make a difference together
go do something cool that contributes go
volunteer I think if you really want the
closest friendships imaginable you go
volunteer once a month or once a quarter
you just you don't wait for you schedule
it I want you to be the friend that
schedules the contribution
be that friend don't hope that person
comes into your life you're that
scheduler
you're that person who sets that up
you're the person that gets them
together because at some point they'll
take it over in all of my greatest
friendship circles I tend to be the
person who initiates it
and we do something and then sometimes
I'll do it next time like right
just do that
acts of contribution to God do you know
who feel
incredible meaning in their lives
people who cherish their life
cherish it
truly cherish their life
and if you feel like I'm speaking
philosophically to you I'm not I've had
the both the blessing and the very real
difficulties of being with a lot of
people at the end of the life and many
of you know I've volunteered in hospice
I've been with my own father as he
passed away
um
in our home
and I can share with you that
it's not until too late that many people
finally start cherishing
their life
really owning
and appreciating different parts of
their life
and if you can remember to do that
I think something magical happens
that's why I ask everybody go into your
growth day journal every day and capture
any meaningful moment capture any sense
of gratitude capture any event you
didn't like and spin that meaning into
such a way where you acknowledge what's
real but you're back in control of your
emotions feelings and your next actions
it's like by the more often that we
capture moments that we can cherish or
moments that we can learn the more life
becomes more meaningful but absent of
that self-reflection it's just a busy
blur that's why journaling has proven
over and over and over in Psychology
including mental health practices and
yes therapy to dramatically shift
people's thoughts and feelings and life
satisfaction over the long term you want
to feel more meaning and fulfillment in
your life think about life more
read some philosophy read some great
biographies of people who did great
things expand your vision
as soon as you expand your vision
there's a different sense of I would say
emotion and motion in life
expand that Vision again
open up that ambition again
now most people don't do that because
well you'd understand Brennan I got
disappointed
I failed they don't believe in me I'm
like and
if you let every disappointment or
failure or discourage are out there
pull at your life philosophy and where
you're going in the future if you forget
that you are destined for greatness by
God or you are destined for goodness by
higher power or if you don't believe in
any of that if you forgot the connection
to your own future in which you want
abundance and joy and amazing things for
your family
well then we got pulled into the mud
didn't we you have to adore people if
you don't adore the person that you are
with right now you have to re-summon
that up you have to look for the things
in them that will help you do that and
the way they do that give them more
attention show them more appreciation
when they receive more attention and
more appreciation from you there there
are being energetic change in the
relationship it will turn more vibrant
more there'll be more pop in it and all
of a sudden you'll start to notice that
person They Come A Little More Alive
around you and it'll be easier to adore
them because oh look I never even
noticed they do these things that's
funny or oh gosh I never noticed they
did all these things for me I I have
attention to that now and I appreciate
that now you'll start to adore them more
when you adore the person with you with
more you do things for them you do more
things for them you want to see them
light up you start supporting their
dreams more how are you doing that
because real adoration is getting out of
your own way and asking what is it about
this person's life that I can support
that they love to do because showing
real adoration is showing support real
adoration is not just doting on somebody
with Flowers and Gifts though you should
do that too it's about wanting to
support their bigger life goals their
bigger dreams when you truly adore
somebody you want so desperately to see
them happy and passionate engage living
their own fully charged life when you
really adore someone you go out of your
way out of your way to brag about them
in front of them right when they're
there and you're in a social situation
you'll you'll you'll compliment them
you'll you'll brag about them and you'll
make them like if you haven't made your
partner your spouse Your Love or your
husband your wife blush for a while with
a good compliment in front of other
people what are you doing right I'm
always trying to embarrass my poor lady
you know and but in a positive way
because I'll compliment her in front of
other people and she's like I really
appreciate you said that about me
because I want her to feel adored I want
everybody in the community I want
everybody in my life to know how much I
adore my lady so do you have that
intention for yours for the person
you're sure with does everybody know how
much you adore them are you bragging
them up are you really adoring them
personally and publicly when you do that
you'll notice a different level of
Engagement in that relationship too and
everything will change because they will
feel adored appreciated and feel like
you're giving them attention so they'll
turn it around now they'll give you more
attention more appreciation more Dorsey
adoration and there'll be this spark and
it happens between the two of you that
you never imagined that you could have
that is what it feels like to live the
charge light
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more Brendan burchard check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there double down on
your goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 2020 you want to find
purposes here double down on your
goodness adopt the role model mindset
and say how can I be a role model